♪ ♪
>> Sean: MR. BATTLE FOR THE
SOUL OF THE NATION JOE BIDEN
WILL USE HIS PRIME TIME
POLITICAL SPEECH TOMORROW TO
LAUNCH MORE BASELESS SMEARS AND
SLANDER AGAINST CONSERVATIVES.
ACCUSING THEM OF BEING THREATS
TO DEMOCRACY, BUT OF COURSE SITS
BY SILENTLY WHILE HIS OWN PARTY
IS ATTACKING AMERICANS EVERY
SECOND OF EVERY HOUR OF EVERY
DAY AND WHITE HOUSE PRESS
SECRETARY KAREEM JEAN-PIERRE
CONFIRMED THAT TO THE SPEECH
WILL BE FILLED WITH MORE
RECKLESS RHETORIC AND RAGE.
LIKE EARLIER IN THE WEEK WHEN HE
USED THE WORD FASCIST.
SPEAK OF THE PRESIDENT THINKS
THERE IS AN EXTREMIST THREAT TO
OUR DEMOCRACY AND THE PRESIDENT
HAS BEEN CLEAR AS HE CAN BE ON
THE PARTICULAR PIECE WHEN WE
TALK ABOUT A DEMOCRACY AND WE
TALK ABOUT OUR FREEDOMS, THE WAY
THAT HE SEES AS THE MAGA
REPUBLICANS ARE THE MOST
ENERGIZED PART OF THE PARTY,
THIS IS AN EXTREME THREAT TO THE
DEMOCRACY AND OUR RIGHTS.
>> Sean: SPEAKING OUT AGAINST
THE 574 RIOTS IN THE SUMMER OF
2020, BUT OF COURSE IT EXTENDS
WAY BEYOND WASHINGTON, BECAUSE A
WEEK AFTER THE REGULATORS PUT
FORWARD A NEW RULE FACING OUT
GAS POWERED CARS BY 2035,
CALIFORNIA, THE GOLDEN STATE IS
NOW TELLING ELECTRIC CAR DRIVERS
TO AVOID CHARGING YOUR VEHICLES
A MIDSUMMER BLACKOUTS AS IT IS
THE FAR LEFT POLICY GOING FROM
BAD TO WORSE.
A PREVIEW OF COMING ATTRACTIONS
TO THE NEW GREEN DEAL SOCIALISM
THAT JOE BIDEN AND THE DEMOCRATS
ONE FOR THE ENTIRE COUNTRY.
EVEN ELON MUSK PROBABLY AGAINST
HIS OWN FINANCIAL INTEREST,
BECAUSE HE SELLS ELECTRIC CARS
HAS SAID REPEATEDLY WE NEED TO
PRODUCE MORE FOSSIL FUEL ENERGY,
AND HEAR WITH MARCO RUBIO, YOU
REALLY CAN'T MAKE IT UP.
BY A MACK AN ELECTRIC VEHICLE,
PAY 20 GRAND MORE.
FORGET ABOUT THE MINING OF
MOTHER EARTH WITH BIG HEAVY
EQUIPMENT RUN BY DIESEL FUEL.
AND IN COLD BOLT NICKEL AND
OTHER MINERALS, FORGET THE FACT
THAT THE ELECTRIC GRID TO LET MY
GREATEST RUN ON FOSSIL FUELS,
GET THE VEHICLE, BUT DON'T
CHARGE THE VEHICLE, YOU REALLY
CAN'T MAKE IT UP, SENATOR.
SPEAK OF THE PROBLEM IN ONE OF
THE CRITICAL PROBLEMS IN THE
LEFT-WING POLICY LIKE THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY THESE DAYS IS
THAT THEY DON'T MESH WITH
COMMON SENSE REALITY IN THE
DIGITAL WORLD, SO THEY HAVE
THESE POLICIES WHERE WE WILL
GIVE BATTERY-POWERED SOLAR
PANEL, WE DON'T HAVE THE
INFRASTRUCTURE OR ANYWHERE NEAR
THAT.
ALL OF THE TAX LEVELS IN THE
WORLD WILL NOT CHANGE THAT,
NUMBER TWO, THE MATERIALS THAT
YOU NEED TO BUILD THESE
BATTERIES AND SOLAR PANELS ARE
LOOKING AT THEM.
AND AS WE POINTED OUT TODAY WE
DON'T HAVE THE CHARGING STATIONS
AND IF WE DO, THEY ARE NOT
LOOKING AT CHARGING THE ELECTRIC
CARS, THE 97% OF CARS DRIVEN ON
THE ROAD BY REAL DAY AMERICANS
REQUIRE GASOLINE.
AND WE ARE NOT PROVIDING MORE OF
IT, AND DOING THINGS THAT HURT
THE ECONOMY AND REALLY HURT
PEOPLE'S POCKETBOOKS.
>> Sean: SO NOW THE PRESIDENT
WILL GIVE THE POLITICAL SPEECH
TOMORROW WHICH I FIND PRETTY
INTERESTING TALKING ABOUT THE
SOUL OF THE NATION, A GUY THAT
REFERRED TO HAVE THE COUNTRY AS
SEMI FASCIST, AND REMEMBER THE
INAUGURATION SPEECH TALKING
ABOUT UNITY.
IN ALMOST SOUNDS LIKE ARE YOU OR
HAVE YOU EVER BEEN A SUPPORTER
OF CONSERVATISM AND
DONALD TRUMP?
THAT'S WHAT IT IS BEGINNING TO
SOUND LIKE TO ME, SENATOR.
IT'S BECAUSE THEY ARE TWO THINGS
HAPPENING HERE, THEY ARE
CRITICIZING OPPOSITION.
SO THIS IS WHAT THEY HAVE BEEN
DOING FOR A WHILE, WHEN YOU LOOK
AT THE FAKE VOTER RIGHTS THING,
NO VOTER RIGHTS IN GEORGIA FOR
EXAMPLE, GAVE THE SPEECH THAT
ANYONE WHO DID NOT SUPPORT THE
BILL THEY WANTED WAS A JIM CROW
OBSERVATION LIST WHICH IS
OUTRAGEOUS AND ABSURD, THEN WE
SOLD ATTACKS AGAINST THE
SUPREME COURT CALLING THEM
ILLEGITIMATE THEY SEE YOU
FINALLY MEANT THAT THESE WEREN'T
REAL JUDGES AND SAW THEM COME
ACROSS THE COUNTRY AND TRY TO
KILL A SUPREME COURT JUSTICE IN
BRETT KAVANAUGH.
AND SEEING PRO-LIFE GROUPS BEING
ATTACKED AND FIREBOMBED.
THE NEXT THING YOU SEE IS ANY
CRITICISM, YOU CRITICIZE THE FBI
AND YOU GET UNPRECEDENTED IRS,
AND WE ARE NOW BEING THREATENED,
IN ESSENCE, THEY HAVE NOW
ESTABLISH THE FIELDS WHERE IF
YOU CRITICIZE THEM, THEY WILL
CLAIM THAT YOU ARE PUTTING THEM
IN DANGER.
TODAY ON THE OTHER HAND DO NOT
CRITICIZE REPUBLICANS, THEY TRY
TO DEHUMANIZE SMEAR REPUBLICANS
BY CALLING NOT TO REPUBLICAN
OFFICEHOLDERS, BUT REPUBLICAN
VOTERS EVERYDAY PEOPLE BY
CALLING THEM SEMI FASCIST, LAST
WEEK IN FLORIDA CHARLIE CRIST
RUNNING FOR GOVERNOR ONCE AGAIN
HERE SAID THAT HE DID NOT WANT
THE SUPPORT OF ANYONE WHO HAD
VOTED DOORS SUPPORTED
RON DeSANTIS, IN ESSENCE,
THAT -- THEY ARE NOT ATTACKING
POLITICAL LEADERS ALONE, THEY
ARE ATTACKING VOTERS, WHICH IS
THE MAJORITY, BECAUSE
DONALD TRUMP WON THE STATE BY
FOUR POINTS.
>> Sean: AS I HAVE BEEN
DIGGING INTO YOUR OPPONENT'S
RECORD, LOOKS LIKE SHE NEARLY
VOTES WITH THE NANCY PELOSI 100%
OF THE TIME.
I DON'T KNOW IF THE PEOPLE OF
FLORIDA KNOW THAT.
SHE PRAISED DEFUNDING THE POLICE
WHICH IS -- I DON'T KNOW IF THAT
IS WHY YOU GOT THE SUPPORT.
AND SAID THAT THE CRISIS AT OUR
BORDER, WHICH IS UNPRECEDENTED,
A 30-YEAR HIGH, SOMETHING THAT
WAS A NORMAL THING, SHE MADE ALL
OF THOSE COMMENTS, AND WHAT IS
THE EXACT PERCENTAGE OF THE TIME
SHE VOTES WITH NANCY PELOSI?
>> NO, IT IS 100% PURE AND SHE
HAS NEVER BROKEN FROM
NANCY PELOSI ONCE.
IT WOULD BE LIKELY SHE WOULD
SELECT HER FROM FLORIDA.
BUT IT GOES FURTHER THAN THAT.
SHE IS FLUSH WITH MONEY PER
DEMOCRATS ALL OVER THE COUNTRY
ARE POURING MONEY INTO HER
CAMPAIGN, RON JOHNSON, SAME
THING HERE.
I NEED PEOPLE'S HELP.
MY WEBSITE IS Marco Rubio.com
I ASK YOU TO HELP, BECAUSE WE
WILL BE OUT FUNDED BY THE FAR
LEFT.
SHE DOES THESE ZOOM CALLS WITH
SMALL GROUPS OF LIBERALS SAYING
INFLATION IS NOT IMPORTANT,
LET'S PUT THAT TO THE SIDE AND
NOT TALK ABOUT INFLATION, THAT
IS NOT OUR TOP PRIORITY.
IT TELLS YOU HOW DISCONNECTED
SHE IS FROM EVERYDAY PEOPLE.
BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY IT TELLS
YOU HOW RADICAL THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY HAS BECOME ON
SOME OF THE HIS IDEAS.
SHE IS A RADICAL RUBBER-STAMP.
IT >> Sean: THEY CAN'T RUN ON
THE BORDER, CERTAINLY.
WILL THEY CLAIM SUCCESS ON THAT?
40 YEAR HIGH OF INFLATION,
RECORD HIGH GAS PRICES, A
DISASTROUS FOREIGN POLICY.
WE DON'T HAVE LAW AND ORDER.
THEY SUPPORT DEFUND, DISMANTLE,
NO BAIL.
OUR SCHOOL SYSTEM, CRTV, AGE
INAPPROPRIATE MATERIALS BEING
TAUGHT IN SCHOOL, WHAT ARE THEY
GOING TO RUN ON, SENATOR?
>> VAL DEMINGS SAYS THAT THE
BORDER CRISIS IS NOTHING NEW
WHEN NOTHING IMPORTANT THERE.
INFLATION IS SOMETHING WE NEED
TO PUT IN A CORNER AND NOT BE
FOCUSED ON.
SHE CLEARLY IS -- SHE TRIES TO
PORTRAY YOURSELF AS A
LAW ENFORCEMENT.
SHE WAS ONCE A POLICE OFFICER.
THAT'S BEEN A LONG TIME AGO.
IN THE LAST SIX YEARS IN
CONGRESS SHE HAS TURNED HER BACK
ON POLICE DEPARTMENTS AND
LAW ENFORCEMENT, THAT'S WHY THEY
HAVE ENDORSED ME.
SHE HAS HELPED THE LEFT ATTACKED
THEM, AS HE POINTED ON.
SHE WILL RUN ON THE MAINSTREAM
MEDIA AND CALLING REPUBLICANS
AND PEOPLE WHO VOTE FOR THEM
FASCISTS.
>> Sean: SENATOR, YOUR SEAT IS
CRITICAL IF REPUBLICANS ARE TO
HAVE ANY HOPE OF RETAKING THE
SENATE.
SAME WITH RON JOHNSON, AND WE
WILL BE FOLLOWING YOUR RACE
CLOSELY.
PEOPLE SHOULD